we're going to begin this hour with the
first case of the omicron coronavirus
it's been detected in this country now
it was detected in california in a fully
vaccinated san francisco resident who is
not yet eligible for a booster shot the
person returned from south africa on
november 22nd they tested positive for
covet 19 this past monday and the strain
was confirmed as omicron just yesterday
dr anthony fauci says a person is
experiencing mild symptoms which are
improving close contacts have tested
negatives so far after first being
identified in south africa last week the
omicron variant has now been detected in
more than 25 countries we're joined now
by white house covet 19 response
coordinator that's jeff science jeff
really good to see you
perfect to have you on
to sort all this out for us you know all
the experts kept saying it's coming it's
coming it's coming it's only a matter of
time and yesterday it was a time how
widespread do you think the variant is
in this country do we have a handle on
that yet
well we are prepared um and as you said
uh the president's been clear and his
medical advisors have been clear that
the variant will come to the country and
we did get our first case yesterday we
are prepared in that we are doing a lot
of genomic sequencing to identify the
cases early and when a case is
identified like yesterday the right
appropriate public health actions
are
put in place including quarantine and
contact tracing i think today is a very
important day and the president is
rolling out
a robust plan for the winter to address
this new variant and covet overall
he's pulling out all the stops
you mentioned what does that mean jeff
what are the new what are the new stats
what are the when you say playing
stops what does that mean i'll start and
i'll highlight a few of the many actions
uh the most important is getting people
boosted you mentioned it earlier gail
boosting provides the highest level of
protection yet for an individual against
the
against the virus and is really
important as we prepare for winter and
the variant
so there's a national campaign
to get the hundred million eligible
americans who have not yet gotten their
booster a booster including increasing
the availability of appointments at
pharmacies walk-ups at pharmacies
expanding our capacity across the whole
network so people can get booster shots
partnering partnering with the aarp to
make sure that seniors understand the
importance of getting a booster shot as
soon as possible providing free rides at
the same time as you know a few weeks
ago vaccines became available for kids
ages 5 to 11. we have 4 million kids
already who have received their first
shot
more and more kids hundreds of thousands
are getting their first shot each day we
want to continue to accelerate that the
president is announcing hundreds of new
family vaccination sites where kids can
get vaccinated but their parents can
also get their first shot if they're not
yet vaccinated or a grandparent can
bring a grandchild the grandparent can
get their booster shot while the child
gets their first shot so family
vaccination sites hundreds across the
countries the other place i'd emphasize
is testing so these are proven practices
we know spotting the disease early
controls its spread at-home testing has
really taken off the president has
through his actions across the last few
months quadrupled the supply of at-home
testing we're going to make sure that
at-home testing is covered by commercial
insurance 150 million americans have
private insurance those insurance
companies now must cover the cost of at
home testing at the same time we're
going to have tens of millions of at
home tests available at community sites
convenient community sites acro around
the country so anyone can get a free
at-home test and testing
testing combined with vaccination will
help control the spread of the disease
and accelerate our path out of the
pandemic
jeff you mentioned pulling out all the
stops the administration stopping people
from traveling from south africa where
it was first reported but it was in the
netherlands before that does that mean
that we should expand the travel ban
well it's really important that we have
very strict protocols on international
travel it's important
to
stop travel from those locations that i
see on the screen because there are
hundreds of cases
in southern africa
that gives us time to prepare
do the type of robust preparation i
talked about with more booster shots
getting more kids vaccinated expanding
testing at the same time travel
protocols are really important you
already have in place in this country
strict travel protocols you need to be
vaccinated to travel to the u.s from a
foreign country we are now
tightening the testing requirement for
international travelers every
international traveler needs to
test within one day
of departure to the u.s uh that'll help
control the spread of the disease and at
the same time the president's announcing
today
just one other important thing on travel
the president is announcing today that
he's expanding the masking requirement
for all domestic and international
travelers
uh uh for through march so there's an
extension of the mass requirement on
travel
well all we can do is just keep putting
the word out there people certainly have
the information as all the experts say
everybody just do your part we can get
through this thank you very much jeff
science for your time this morning
one more word it's so important that if
you're not vaccinated get vaccinated
take your kids and get them vaccinated
and then boosters boosters provide the
highest level of protection if you don't
have your booster shot go get your
booster shot today yeah i'm happy to say
i got my booster too thank you jeff
thank you very much